[Music]
if you ever wanted to see with the kids
of some of Disney's most iconic villains
look like you absolutely have to watch
descendants the popular movies are a
favorite among Disney fans and today
we'll show you some of the most stunning
cartoon fan art stick around to see the
whole group in action don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out 10 the Symons two characters
reimagined add cartoons
now although mal is a natural-born
leader and popular with almost everyone
she can be incredibly vengeful after all
she's the daughter of Maleficent and she
has her own kind of persuasion mal
teaches us there are so many ways to be
wicked in the second dissonance movie we
still love her awesome look and we found
some amazing cartoon versions of her
character check out these absolutely
stunning illustrations which belongs to
a talented Instagram user Keely V Cortez
77 doesn't she look like a Bratz doll we
just adore her purple look that would
definitely make her stand out in the
cartoon world
here's another slightly darker looking
illustration of now created by bohat Elf
- art on tumblr don't forget she's
rotten to the core after all Evie
not only is Evie mouths best friend but
she's also the daughter of the Evil
Queen Evie eventually learns that looks
aren't everything and that finding the
prince charming isn't all you should do
in life just like her best friend Evie
is a colorful character that would make
a perfect cartoon check her out
the first couple of illustrations belong
to the talented Kiwi B Cortes 77 then we
have unicorn smile from deviantART who
showed us a very fabulous
Evie as well as another photo of mal
pray girl also illustrated the two best
friends hanging out together can you
spot their mothers and the poster in the
background Evie's blue style would
definitely work perfectly for a cartoon
character
Carlos Carlos is the son of Cruella De
Vil he was brought up in a slightly
different way from the rest of the
characters but that doesn't mean he's
any more or less important than the rest
of the game with his white hair he
stands out from the crowd but it's
amazing personality that makes us
believe he'd be an awesome cartoon
character both of these illustrations
belong to Keeley P Cortes 77 from
Instagram the first one shows us a
freckled version of Carlos holding out
an apple however in the second
illustration Carlos turned into one of
the most adorable cartoon characters
we've ever seen we can totally see this
tiny character run away from dogs and
being all anxious and jumpy
jay-j is definitely the eye candy of the
group he's tall muscular brave and he's
super athletic but don't be fooled by
his charms he's Jafar son which means he
isn't really up to anything good because
Jay and Carlos are like two peas in a
pod
we found a bunch of illustrations
showing them what they look like in the
cartoon world first belongs to Eber Nico
from deviantART who also did a close
swap with the two characters we love
Carlos's cartoon hair Disney Channel
Freak also created her version of what
the two would look like as BFFs in the
cartoon world if you stay with me
forever from tumblr combined with the
world of Harry Potter and hi Lauri gave
us a little taste of Jay and Carlos as a
couple aren't they totally adorable
Chad charming in the first movie he had
the hots for chad charming but in
descendants - chad has a completely
different storyline that doesn't really
paint him in a good light let's just say
him and Jay don't get along we've seen
several versions of Prince Charming in
the cartoon world but here's Prince Chad
charming the first illustration belongs
to Maile Mouse 101 from deviantART who
put Chad in a snazzy blue outfits
however burned one to get to the next
level and transform Chad into the actual
Prince Charming from Cinderella days
doesn't he look as handsome as ever
here's another Chad illustration made by
DJ - nyan mouse we have to admit we
weren't really impressed by Chad's charm
in The Descendants movies uma now let's
talk about one of the coolest characters
we got to meet in dissonance - she might
be the villain of the story but we are
totally jealous of her awesome hair and
an even better style but these
illustrations prove she look even more
awesome as a cartoon character the first
one belongs to the Nora
uma look even fiercer than she already
is charcoal terkoz also gave an
interesting spin to her look we totally
imagine this version of uma being an
actual cartoon villain Josh Stacy from
deviantART turns her into a cute cartoon
character and Keeley B Cortez 77 made
her look completely adorable descendants
two wouldn't be the same without Emma
Ben King ven aka King obviously cute is
known as the son of Belle and beast and
he's definitely nailing his character
he's friendly honest and sweet exactly
what you'd expect from someone being
raised by Del Ben's pretty handsome but
his cartoon character is totally
adorable check him out Kili v Cortes 77
reimagined him as one of the cutest
characters we've ever seen and look at
those gorgeous blue eyes and though lair
from deviantART made him even more
handsome than he is in real life we also
love as arenas cartoon version of venom
mal together they're our favorite couple
in the movie we have to admit we're
totally swoon for Ben's looks and
personality good choice now kill most of
the dissonance characters are known for
their strong personalities which they've
inherited from their headstrong parents
gill is the spitting image of his
pompous dad Gaston but the main
difference between the two is that Gil
is incredibly loyal to Emma and the rest
of his crew although he's the antagonist
in the movie he's definitely a likeable
character
we'd love these adorable illustrations
made by Keeley B Cortez 77 on Instagram
this version of appeal comes with big
eyes an even bigger head and an adorable
look overall speaking of being loyal to
his crew check out this illustration
created by Mac Sierra on tumblr this
cartoon version of Gil is painting
Yuma's nails while Harry is messing with
his eyeliner sounds like something a
cartoon pirate crew would do Harry hook
it almost seems impossible that Captain
Hook would have a son but Harry hooks is
a living proof of the spat like a true
pirate Harry is completely wild and
unpredictable and is always ready to
defend Ouma
the rest of his crew this story is
interesting but Sora's cartoon versions
the talented QEP Cortez 77 did it again
and gave hairy and adorable cartoon look
that makes you slightly less
intimidating meanwhile Jett Knights
version is also fantastic
why - Yuki from deviantART decided to
take on the entire hook family and we
can definitely see the similarities
between the three characters Captain
Hook sure looks like he has a lot on his
plate and we've loved to see more of his
family whole group ever since the first
movie Mau et Carlos and Jay became
hugely popular characters the
descendants have taken over the world
with their heads strong personalities
and we love every single character let's
see what all of them would look like in
a cartoon form Kili be Cortez 77 turned
the four into pretty believable
characters and Gen Y 235 from deviantART
created stunning fan art of them fitting
perfectly into their cartoon characters
the talented uber - Nico gave them
unique personalities and Buttercup 1f
showed that they're really rotten to the
core and even though they were raised by
the biggest villains in Disney history
you have to admit that the descendants
are pretty likable do you have a
favorite character let us know in the
comments below that's it for descendants
two characters reimagined as cartoons
for more videos like this one check out
10 descendants characters we imagined is
a loud house see you next time
[Music]